should i do headphones too might
you can you look great i mean i don't
want to i don't want to throw off the
look you know
you've got yeah the gun the gun shows in
town
this is the only shirt i could find i
don't know
i don't know where anything is
well that uh indicates a poorly executed
move
dude no one ever knows wherever it is
it's fine
i can't i can't begin to explain
i don't do well
i don't do well in chaos i'm
great with challenges like
i did this um i directed this commercial
shoot
last weekend was that the water stuff
yeah and i walked in and the team's
great
but literally everything typically every
shoot that i come in with it's like all
right
this is what i'm going to do and here's
kind of my vibe and then invariably what
producers do they go
ah go to that
i'm like cool i was like and we found
out like the pool that we were shooting
it was like four
feet deep so
all of the shots that i had set up
weren't gonna work
and so i was like is that too deep or
not deep enough for what you were trying
to do
enough like i was i was expecting to get
like full underwater shots of people and
they're like
it's four feet deep unless you're
shooting crosstalk
okay cool and so i can like adapt and
move in those situations
where i don't do well like when i walk
into like when i check into a hotel
the first i think we talked about this
before the first thing that i do
continental breakfast well yeah
so i always make sure that my flight
gets in before 11 a.m
[Laughter]
i just need you to be going continental
continental breakfast um i
i have to unpack everything in my
suitcase everything in my like
toiletries
everything goes hung up in the wardrobe
or in
shelves done wow where we are
exactly opposite in that way
mike mike's my boy you're gonna get
the first thing i have to do is unpack
everything and put it in the right
places for sure
it's my trips with like people i work
with they all laugh at me for
i immediately have to go to my room and
unpack yeah it's see
that to me i can't
help but shake the paranoia that i'm
going to lose something if i
nest to that degree no
so you're living out the bag the whole
trip i live out of the bag
yeah i never is there is there a limit
i've i've never not done that so
whatever the longest trips i've ever
taken it's still held true
the the the exception would be if i need
to
something shouldn't get wrinkled like if
i have a suit like there's an event or
something
as part of the travel i will hang that
but i never ever use the drawers
in the uh the dresser
one jacket and you own one nice
button-down shirt
pointing
for the record i own multiple shirts
i do i technically have a tux
a very cheap not particularly
nice one but i do have a jacket for the
tux separate from my beloved hugo
that is my one actual indulgent piece of
clothing that i ever bought in my life
does the toothpaste
and the toothbrush go in the bathroom or
does that stay
adjacent to the bag or in the bag those
do do live in the bathroom
but okay okay but they don't they don't
come out of
the toiletries bag that i put in the
bathroom
really so you don't even okay well i
guess i leave the toothbrush
out to dry like overnight or in the
morning after i use it that but that's
right
it's not home a hotel room is is a
better stop it's better than home
somebody else is
going to clean it i mean
yeah i get it i get it i don't know so
what do you not worry i always even
though i don't bring
that much to your point i don't bring
like hugely valuable
things when i travel typically like my
laptop might
usually be the only thing that's kind of
high risk loss like if i lose a t-shirt
you know i can i can handle it but i
still have a
an inherent paranoia that if i spread
myself
out uh i'll never possibly find it even
even with
the tiny amount that i bring it just
feels like maybe i just stay in smaller
hotel rooms than you maybe that's what
it is
okay well it's not like i don't know
what he's saying i know what you're
saying yeah like it's good and i've
definitely lost stuff i've definitely
left stuff in hotel rooms for sure
yeah maybe this all stems from i love a
piece of clothing
when we when i was a kid we did a road
trip across
canada we took the one road and
uh i had a 1983
ewok stuffed teddy bear and i left it in
a hotel room and it probably is all
because of that
there we go we saved so much on
psychiatry via this show don't we
we've gotten we've worked it out we've
solved this three
years nothing but you've gotten to the
bottom of it how does that make you feel
austin
nothing beats the intersection of star
wars and therapy
uh basically so yeah
here's a question here's a follow-up
question that seems tangential
but it's actually related on
average how many alarms
do you set to wake up
on a typical day or you mean in a hotel
room
i'll take the first answer
and the second answer if it's different
oh it's definitely different because
in a hotel room well especially i
usually just set an alarm
and the one one alarm
i used to do several not because i was
the
snooze you know go into this whole dance
thing but because
if i didn't fully wake up i would turn
it off
get back in bed and and never remember
the first having gone off at all
i'll have total amnesia over it so
because i missed
some alarms a few times from that i
started leaving my phone across the room
or in another room
to force me to literally to go
get it and that at that point i started
using one
ironically you've seen the ones that
have wheels that kind of drive
themselves
yeah like little robots i think it's a
genius idea
you can get like alarm clocks where
they're like it's like a big rotary kind
of
drum thing just and it just rides right
off your
thing and yeah i saw there was a girl
there was a girl on shark tank news
no there was a um there was a girl on a
shark
alarm are you kidding me i would chase
that i'm faster than that alarm clock
and i would pick it up and i would throw
it out the window
there baby up but you'd be able to
that's the thing
there was there was a there was a girl
on shark tank who who had uh
previously made like as a college
you know dorm room bit of
entrepreneurial
hobbying she made a little alarm clock
that was similar and it was like a robot
that you basically
had to catch and uh but i know that
there's others where
you know that to shut off the alarm you
have to solve a puzzle and stuff like
that and
but the funny thing is when we when we
got this dog
six however many months ago um more than
that now
um we at first we had to lock her
in because you know she would just
basically wander around and destroy
everything so the bedroom was all closed
off because normally
i was leaving my phone on the table
outside of the bedroom
uh in order to to get the alarm but then
i had to put it by the bedside so i had
to
rewire my brain to actually wake up
grab an alarm clock within arm's reach
to be woken up by and not fall back
asleep without remembering it so but all
all bets are off if i have a flight to
catch
especially if it's an early flight and
i'm i'm waking up at like four or
something i set like 50 alarms
i i i i i my parent and and then i
don't even sleep because i'm paranoid
i'm not going to wake up
mike i'm one lump yeah i'm uh
i've trained myself i can't i don't i
don't roll over i
i'll get up straight away i just i
because i think it's about
i think where it goes wrong is
variability it's when you sometimes have
an alarm sometimes have two sometimes
have none
no consistency that's how you train
yourself to kind of
i'm a little bit boring i suppose sorry
my girlfriend just brought kerry sorry
you know kerry
kerry's bought me cookies so i'm going
to enjoy my cookie carry on wait a
minute what are you having with that
cookie are you having a diet coke or
having a coffee
i'm having a coffee oh good day good day
it's it's been a decent day yeah it's
been a decent day busy but good you know
carry on troy tell us about your alarm
habits yeah why yeah i was gonna say i
feel like there's a hidden agenda while
you're asking
no it's it's uh to me in the same way
of you know what do you do when you
first get to a hotel is kind of
revelatory about the person i feel like
the alarm clock situation is the same
thing
because i was the same i would set 50
alarms
and it was like the peewee hermann
gauntlet of
things that would get me going and i
when i there was this brief period of
time i was like i guess i was
20 19 or 20.
and i this is a bad living situation but
i ended up having to live with my uncle
and i had to sleep on a couch
that their dog would [ __ ] and piss on
and they wouldn't clean it up so i had
to clean it up and i had
like a little corner to put all of my
stuff
in and the only thing that i had was
this alarm that was on a battery-powered
calculator
and it would just go
the quietest chirp ever that that was a
battery-powered calculator so not
like an abacus uh we're talking we're
talking 20th century technology here
it could be no but it could have been
like solar powered
i would argue still a battery but
i just love this i just love the i love
the distinction
a plug-in calculator i love that idea
you have to go like this and then i
would call mabel
i want to connect yeah i was going to
say i want one that you wind yeah
exactly you got to build a charge
and ian all that i had and i had to get
up at
5 like 5 45 5 30 in the morning every
morning
to uh either a catch the bus
which i never done before um or
my uncle would he work downtown i work
downtown this is in dallas
and either he would if i wasn't
downstairs waiting for him he would
leave
and so i would have to figure i would go
to work that day so
it was it was a rough time so once i had
that i was like oh
same thing as mike like you train
yourself and you realize if you don't
have any other recourse if you don't
have a backup it's amazing what you can
accomplish
that is definitely when you have to do
something
and there's nobody else like right now
with this house like nobody else is
gonna do this [ __ ]
i gotta figure it out should you uh
explain to our
dear audience why your location is
different
your zoom background yeah so this is the
weirdest zoom background ever
so we moved and we moved out to the
country
and um
there were four guys that came to our
house
with two trucks two
two big trucks
and they filled it up with just all of
our stuff
and it's i don't know i don't know a lot
mike you're about to be in the process
of this
there are things that you will discover
you're like
i didn't i forgot we had this and i will
i will remember
buying it and going this thing is so
important it's so important
amazon had to get it to me that day that
day i wouldn't wait
two days and i forgot we had i'm like
this is
it's it's been a really really
interesting time
but uh yeah so we we got new digs and
i've got
no setup right now i i can't find
i barely found my feet this morning
proving once and for all that you are a
mr potato head i'm loving the color of
that wall behind you genuinely don't
love it don't fall in love with it
really is it it's all getting changed
the only room in the house
that i like that red though the yellow
less so but the red's nice man
yeah it looks a bit [ __ ]
i yeah and the sausage in front of us in
the hospital yeah
do you like that every room but this
room got painted
and uh that's that's my room is that
kind of
is that some kind of revenge like is
that some sort of you you [ __ ] up and
that was your subtle little subversive
just irony it's just irony is it
literally an oversight
or or you it's just a place it's a
planning thing because
um this this is kind of temporary i'm
going to
kind of get a a more permanent solution
um
and so you want to rebuild your studio
right you've got to do the whole
the whole yeah are you walking um
when you first arrived and they came the
you know the folks who were helped
setting things up did they come meet you
nervously and you were like
dispense with the pleasantries i'm here
to put you back on schedule
is that how that went down there was
none of that they they were really cool
they had great vibe they're like
are you ready we're like yeah and pamela
started crying she was like i don't know
she's done such a great job imagine if
the opening of return of the jedi had
been like that
are you ready are you ready
vader i don't know oh no
somebody please dub that tub that scene
with the audience that we just made
i still giggle at that terminator one
from ages ago
the best that's
they did okay he's like
with the responses from people i
couldn't tell if they if they had
or if it was just they were hoping and
then people were membing it i
don't know what it
that exact same thing with uh
the new metroid though uh because i saw
so that's real too
yeah i saw so many people finally that's
been in development or it's been
announced what ten years now so that's
that's why i didn't know if it was real
because i
i just kept seeing people talk about
metroid but i couldn't find it took me
longer than it should have to find like
the actual
content of an announcement it was just
people talking about metroid now the
problem is people talk about
metroid 24 7 all day all year
like someone somewhere is it so it's
it's like the signal to noise ratio made
it actually
hard to know did i miss that one and
it's real or is it just another year of
like
boo no metroid did they keep it this
i mean i don't have to watch it but just
for sake of conversation did they keep
it the same
format did they change anything is it
now like oh in metroid
yeah they've got no it's that's what's
exciting about it to me is they've gone
back to the side on view so it looks
weirdly looks like shadow complex which
of course
actually looks like metroid but like
that's it's yeah that 3d side view which
is really interesting
yeah what was the one that they did like
2004 2006 that was like
samus talked and it was just it was like
let's let's modernize
2576 without been
i can't remember they all blur together
just it's a great game go back to like
making it a side scroller like that's
that's all that it needs to be it's
super challenging more hyped than any of
the first person versions like i'm
super there for a side on version of
metroid again because
long ago it was man it's such a
challenging game and it's so
weird too it's got that like hr i don't
know if i'm going to say this right some
people say giger some people say geiger
but it's like
that whole let me consider please
oh that's right you have the book but
does it have a pronunciation
i've pulled that out before we're not
doing that again we're fine
for the record i thought it was
i always make a point of pronouncing it
the opposite way to the person i'm
talking to
just to make them walk away from the
conversation and go yeah
is it gay
i've never been which sounds like a
limerick go to the geeker museum in
gruyere i want to go to the giger isn't
there like a hotel
that's like a restaurant there's like a
restaurant where the chairs are all
yeah it's right across from the museum
really
oh really i thought this was i thought
this is this
small like medieval village that you can
walk in like 15 minutes and the
second that you get to this to the like
the the
the outer courts of this town it smells
like cheese and you're like oh i just
smell the gruyere cheese
and then you walk through and you're
like i can't go in that building because
that's where they make
cheese i'm gonna throw up it's so bad
but you walk through the giger museum
and it's just a lot of dicks and a lot
of
like just the most satanic oh my god
so that's why i'm doing zoom on my phone
does it keep screw timing out your
screen yeah
it is it is the the and then you can go
go across and it's this whole
alien themed bar so you get these crazy
concoctions and drinks
point of order it's in switzerland did
you say france it's in switzerland
yes in switzerland sorry the town name
is correct
it's just that town here in switzerland
yeah but there are two bars
uh one across from the hotel one in a
different
switzerland town one is the giger bar
and the other one is the museum giger
bar
so mine the one i'm talking about is the
museum right third one was located in
tokyo in the 80s
but then i think that's the one i was
talking about because i've seen photos
of the tokyo what do you mean
located did someone stumble upon it like
they were doing like an uh
archaeological dig and they're like oh
my god we found another there was this
weird obelisk and the people went like
wow there's tables
that's basically uh that's basically how
the alien versus predator movies like
with an elephant face yeah the whole
thing goes that's the that's the kind of
linear
timeline shenanigans of the avp movies
where it's like they discover that it's
just they've been here all along
and yeah no good no good but
lance henry okay lance hendrickson in
aliens or lance hendrickson
in alien versus predator what about it
which is better everything is better in
aliens
yeah i was going to say the alien verse
predator will lose that competition no
matter
if even if we're talking about best
alien versus predator movie compared to
aliens
aliens i would i would bet i would bet
the catering was better on aliens like i
bet every aspect of that production
cameron looks after his own i i just
i think that lance hendrickson aged
so well that the character
that he plays because obviously he plays
um oh my gosh uh
oh god i'm the same i started to say
bishop uh bishop
um no that is right it's why did that
why does that feel real first is isn't
bishop in the first
yeah okay i was gonna say that that's an
alien that's this doesn't feel right and
i don't like that i don't know that you
know
it's bishop and i had a friend that had
a cat's name bishop that's bishop
and it is bishop yeah but it's bishop
and there's a
who are you trying to think of hicks no
it's bishop and ripley
who's who's what's the name of the
android in alien though
yeah no i mean but in alien it's some
because it's uh what's his name
great british actor who i'm forgetting
the name of as well
david attenborough
i i hate it this is a bad podcast guys
this is ash ash you're right
yeah oh yeah ian holm i was gonna say i
am certain that it's
bishop um from aliens but i could not
remember ash to save my life
but lance hendrickson in why is this
dead lance hendrickson in an alien
versus predator where he he plays kind
of like the
the um he is wayland right he's um
playing the yeah he's like the corporate
the corporate uh
founder of yeah i thought that was super
cool i mean yeah it was i love the idea
i love the idea that
it's the model is based on the
historical record of what that guy
looked like that's cute that's a nice
thing yeah exactly the
on paper i got just as much satisfaction
if i had read that in a paragraph
on imdb than i did from seeing the movie
but yeah
it um the fact that he's like he's
fearless because he knows he's about to
die
and so he's just like [ __ ] your favorite
movie ever isn't it this is making me
want to re-watch the movie because if
anyone could care about it this much
maybe it's better than i thought it was
when i saw it because i remember
writing it off yeah it completely
retcons
so much stuff that is is beloved but it
like
that whole franchise is like that though
even prometheus and covenant also
totally screw up everything i think
covenant's great though
covenant as movies they're okay and and
like
really scott's like production design
and art direction and stuff is basically
unparalleled
but the i will take i genuinely don't
think he's seen any of the other movies
though that's my theory on ridley scott
i don't think he watched
anything are you watching raised by
wolves
i never did i watched the first few
episodes um
i didn't i didn't get all the way
through it though it was yeah i kind of
got
a bit bored i think to be honest like
again visually stunning
i've heard that i heard that it is the
kind of stretch down
it's establishing laura for sure like
he's he's he's ramping everything up
i was we've talked about this before i
was i was talking about
um travis fimmel and i thought he was
great in vikings but it's like
he does this one thing and i'm not
i'm i was like do something different
and he's still doing
in this show and i'm like do something
to
i do like ridley scott if you ever want
a fun afternoon i put on a ridley scott
director's commentary
they're amazing because he's
is that so grumpy and so very british
yeah oh it's brilliant he'll just go off
on one for like 10 minutes about
some executive who was rude to him at a
party or something
it's brilliant was different tony was
like this half-able
lampshade like totally different guy i
wonder where that
when uh covenant came out um
angela got invited to the premiere in
london
to take part in this media event thing
where they were asking questions to
fassbender
and ridley scott and
so she being you know someone who was
coming into it with cosplay experience
and working with a lot of stuff with her
hands you know
she and ridley scott you know with you
know some of these
iconic practical effects um
in his filmography uh
and with just such an incredible visual
sense she said you know do you prefer
practicals models that kind of thing or
or visual effects
and she said she was so disappointed
because she really wanted him to say oh
you know nothing beats the real thing
and he was like oh no
v cg by far because you basically can
just
endlessly iterate until until launch day
yeah i remember she was like
like you do get that sense like he's
he's clearly
and you see you i love this kind of
creator like it's it's what i aspire to
be as well
there's a lack of pretensions the way he
talks about like the the blade runner
commentary
is genuinely excellent because he's just
talking casually about like
you know so many things in blade runner
that are iconic that have like defined
the aesthetics of
that genre of movies ever since and he's
talking about you know
oh yeah yeah well he but he will
literally like he would
i he he gives the example of like he's
he's
he's
oh yeah i was you know i was walking in
la one night and they just cleaned the
clean the
the tarmac and there was war on you know
i looked at that and i thought oh that's
futuristic
and then i went and we we made the floor
where in blade runner and i think that's
why people like it
it's like lovely like that's that's just
like that complete level of just like
i'm giving him a cockney accent which he
doesn't have but yeah anyway
he's that the pillars like the pillars
in the street
in blade runner he said yeah i showed up
and they'd they've done all the the the
props guys they've made the tops of the
pillars really beautiful
but the bottoms were rubbish but the
problem was because
because there's such a small set you can
put the camera up very high so you can
see all the detail
so i said turn those upside down and
they did and that's why that looks like
that it's just a brilliant commentary
because
it's just that kind of it's not not
about like his visions of society
it's just like the practicality of the
craft of making a film yeah and
everything you know 100
love cgi because it just lets him
iterate and fix problems
yeah i love those stories though about
the the the practical
just decision making where it's like hey
do you like uh ketchup or mustard
you know mustard okay and then it's like
then iconic yeah no not the back wall
just the ceiling in the other wall
the number of times people come up to me
and say oh it's so clever how you
made rectangles so emotive what we
that's such an interesting kind of
criticism of
of aaa that you don't need and i'm like
i couldn't afford anything we had
rectangles
it was that you know i love those though
that's the that's the decision making
that's fun in this job
there's a great example of that uh go
ahead i have a go
just help me remember but go ahead oh
[ __ ]
i think she was she was kinder she was
friendlier yeah well it's a it's a
regime change you know it's like
this is what happens in a free society
sometimes you don't like who you get
i i don't know if this is an accurate
question
if it's if it's possible to make it this
binary but
do you believe that it's more important
have you lost his audience this has been
a demonstration of my power
[Laughter]
you suck a bit
wow it is well within my right
oh man now the funny thing that was a
really thoughtful question he was asking
i know
you keep waving it right here we have no
idea what it was people on spotify are
going to be like
everyone's going to like do something
with my earpieces
that's what happened you know the you
know the really sad thing i actually
felt like pangs of guilt and i was like
no just stick it through you'll give
all right me again i won't touch them
do you feel that it's more important to
have
it which is which which is more
important vision or iteration
like if you're like here's my vision i
want to execute it
don't do that i'm not going to fall for
it mike oh you're a writer
i like that you went double in on that
though presuming that
you had been muted to him as well like
yeah i was doing layers of uh just like
i'm just muting everybody i'm just like
completely drunk on power power
this is really what happens when alana
is not here you gotta set five alarms to
be
austin yeah i i absolutely have an
answer to this but mike uh
take it away i didn't it was i was too
busy [ __ ] around to hear that
question what was it
vision or iteration austin you go first
no vamp
well i can i can tell you specifically
from the perspective of working
with a director in both like
i i i will and i will invariably for my
sake
i i always try to start with a vision
like here's my pitch here's the concept
behind the score to xyz
you know it's gonna like journey we it's
all about solo cello the cello is the
player like there is a kind of unified
idea at the heart of it that everything
sort of revolves
relative to in some way but the
iteration being the crucial thing where
sometimes you realize oh the vision
there was a bad it was a flawed premise
and the iteration revealed that
so you you can't vision alone usually
you're basically lucky if it turns out
to be to be perfect now that said
working with a director um
it is far easier to work with a director
that has a strong vision
because the challenge becomes
us aligning and calibrating our language
to make sure that we're talking
about the same thing when talking about
that vision like if they're saying this
but i somehow am thinking of something
else and we end up talking past each
other i'll write the wrong thing
not realizing it's the wrong thing and
then we kind of go in circles and that
can be a challenge
but i'll take that challenge any day
over somebody that just wants to
endlessly try things because
it's you know if someone's like hey
austin
you know let's just like maybe it ought
to be you know big
giant complicated orchestral music and
you spend like three days
doing this thing uh you know i don't
know i thought i liked that but
i don't now that i'm hearing it you know
what if it was like
full four on the floor like you know
like dirty club
german house music you know like you
spent a couple days
producing the [ __ ] out of it no it's not
really that it's
you know how and it's like the lack of
vision jerks you are
it's like you're like the you're like
the fireman on the end of the
you know the the person controlling the
back of the uh
the the giant fire truck you know with
the the steering wheel with the
the uh the giant ladder where as the
front moves
you're supposed to tell the metaphor
your arm is a terrible metaphor
okay fine well then how about this you
are uh you have much of a vision for
this but you are iterating on it well
[Laughter]
true uh you know like if you imagine
being uh the water skier being pulled by
a power boat slightest move in the uh
on the wheel of the boat you swing with
like a 110 degree arc
uh and that getting yanked around in
that way is
far more difficult because at some point
you realize
i shouldn't really commit to this draft
very hard because i'm going to have a
new idea thrown at me tomorrow
and so then the quality of work starts
to come down because you're
you're like well i i'm i'm on shifting's
hands i don't really know
what's what so you know a really hard to
please
strong vision to me as a collaborator
who is
in some sense subservient to that vision
is quite superior it's
easier to work with even though it's
obviously its own challenge so all right
i want you as much time as i can
vamp away it's tricky you know it's a
really
it's a very tough question because the
the other thing
i try to be very conscientious to the
people i work with probably to a fault
all the time like i really want to make
sure i'm working in the way
that people around me want to work so it
does often mean that yeah because
you get you definitely get the one side
of it which is what austin's expressing
which is
just tell me what you want so i can do
it you know that's definitely like one
of the attitudes
and there's a lot of people who like to
work that way but then there's also
people who really want
freedom and creative input and to like
you know
to be the king of their little part of
the project so i try and calibrate
according to that but but yeah i'd say
i'd say
i really like i use as an example all
the time
there's a specific moment i've probably
said this on the show before so
apologies for improving myself
there's a specific moment an episode of
next generation start bring it back to
star trek always bring it back to star
trek
where they land on the planet and i
think it's picard
and cross
oops oh no you've really nothing
hey in in my defense i didn't even look
back to place my hands
that's true yeah though the fair play um
so they land on the planet i think it's
crusher and
and it might be troy and picard but they
uh
the one turns to picardon says which
which way do we need to go and because
it's that way and they go
for um you know 10 minutes 20 minutes
and
the other character says did you did you
know it was this way
and because like no but it's my job to
tell you which way to go and we'll
see where it gets us and that's that's
my view on the vision
it's often actually it is vamping a lot
of time it is going well i don't know
what the solution is i don't know if i
need the big band
or if i need the the solo pianist but i
need austin to feel comfortable enough
that i have a vision so that he feels
comfortable enough to give me the best
answer to that question
so it's often about kind of engaging in
conversation
yeah that's engaged if a director
there's a lot of politics today i guess
there's a lot of
it's it's manipulative to an extent but
i think that's i mean that's
leadership in general is a manipulative
act you are trying to get people around
you to do something
it reminds me i want manipulation i
don't look at that as manipulation in a
negative way not in a negative way but
you are influencing others you are you
are
trying to frame that yeah but i mean in
the same way that encouragement
is manipulation right no but i think
what mike means though is that it's
manipulation from the lens of
if you secretly don't actually know the
answer you know that you'll get
a better response by not letting that on
and saying which i've scared the [ __ ]
out of people in the past right i've
worked with collaborators
where like especially with younger
people who've maybe not got as much
experience
where i've said to them like in
conversations i've said like i'm gonna
be honest with you
i don't know if this needs to be red or
blue
i think probably red but let's try both
and see where we land
that scares the [ __ ] out of a young
person though because they're like well
mike's the director he should know if
it's red or blue and
they're kind of right but it's saying
human you don't know
so often it's actually better to have a
firm
a firm vision that's stated but then to
have the flexibility and the trust with
the people you work with that you can
kind of bend that
it's like you're cooking a meal right
it's like you've got the recipe
but you're very reactive to what happens
in the frying pan right
yeah but there's using that metaphor
there's a difference between a cook and
a chef
a cook is someone who can make a meal a
chef is someone who can run a kitchen
and the difference between those two is
a cook can cook by himself but a chef
needs his team he needs his soup he
needs his sommelier he needs everybody
that works in that kitchen
to able to to be able to execute that
restaurant so
i the if you don't know who ernest
shackleton
is which i'm pretty sure the two of you
do well we've certainly spoken about
shackles and at great length yeah i'm
not sure i do i'm actually going to
admit i don't know who shackles is so
definitely awesome dude like it's
ernest shackleton is
he was a businessman he was he was a
salesman
and he is most famous
for being the person who
sailed down from the uk to antarctica
and he wanted to be the first one to go
around antarctica
and they got they got uh land locked in
ice and i think it was a crew of
300 i can't remember um
and they were trapped for i want to say
it was either six months or it was a
year
and not a single person died
and everyone afterwards when they were
like
how did you feel about this guy
that led you to the most perilous moment
of your life
and every single one of them were like i
would follow him back to this day
and the reason why is he he had no idea
that this ice thing would happen again
noah every time they tried to make
landfall at
hope uh back in in africa
um or south america i can't remember one
of the two
um they kept the tide kept working
against him
and they did so on like a tender it was
like 12 of them i think
on a robo sailing from antarctica up to
around chile so it was south america
and the fact that these people looked at
him is like he had no nautical
experience
he just understood that
people recognized and awarded and he was
would be lauded for
being the first to attempt to do
something and so when his first goal
was missed somebody else did what he
originally wanted he wanted to go to
antarctica first somebody else got there
he was like fine i'll be the first
person to do this and he kept iterating
on his dream on his goal
and even when circumstance and fate
nearly robbed him of not only that but
also his life and all of his crew
and the way that he commissioned his
people he does he was like i don't care
if you're sailors
i want people who have nothing to lose
and
know that you may not make it back this
is the most treacherous
you know uh journey that anybody could
take and he read his crew he knew
exactly who it was
so someone like that is is a leader and
it's it's more about to me being a
leader and
even if you're making basically shepherd
going into the omega relay
that's my analogy well you're playing
mass spec right now hard aren't you
i'm i'm i'm like i'm like the hulk i'm
always playing mass effect art
i don't wanna don't nobody do anything
with that joke because we're just gonna
leave
we're just gonna leave with that thank
you this is what happens when three
dudes are in those podcasts
[Laughter]
uh yeah i i love that it's it's a
fascinating
i've always you read it was a specific
biography about him or something that
really um
um uh put you on there's
there's two and i feel a bit out of
culture all of my books are in boxes
right now um but yeah there's
there's only one that was written by him
um is that the one that you read yeah
um and it's it's pretty it's pretty
revealing because he's
like like ridley scott he's just kind of
like yeah
i had to figure out how to do this and i
convinced people to fund this expedition
uh solely based on the fact that i had
no idea it was going to succeed it could
have failed but it was incredibly
expensive at the time
and he was like yeah i want you know
eleventy billion dollars to go down i
guess it was it was the moon shot of its
day right like it was
the equivalent of all that yeah and most
importantly
that's what everybody was doing is they
were they were it was the moonshot
everybody was going for that and it was
just really
you know kind of i don't know if it was
coming out of this victorian era where
everything that could be discovered
had been discovered and instead people
were like [ __ ] it what else is out there
and that's where darwin comes into play
it's just like it was
this constant challenging of the
infrastructure
people that don't accept the system
that's handed to them and instead either
try to create their own
or break the one that's been given to
them those are
always the people that are the vanguard
for for advancement
that's it's always it's never the people
that play by the rules
that's that's one of neil degrasse
tyson's big
um spiels you know where he says
you know if there hadn't been somebody
who was willing to venture out of the
cave
and risk death we'd still be in the cave
like yeah
like that that's a human instinct you
know that's why
you know it's like we talk so much about
the merits of landing a human on mars
and they say you know by basically every
conceivable measure
it's better to send rovers you know the
the ungodly amount of cost associated
with
maintaining the frail human life on the
way there
on the way back on the surface 50
billion things trying to kill you at
every step of the way and a lot of ways
it can go wrong
with no hope of quick rescue all that
it's just like it's it's it's far
exponentially far more fraught than any
expedition even to the moon
uh in the whole history of humanity
could be and so like
intel technology makes it somehow
trivially easy to go there
which you know that's that's that's just
that's an even and if if
such technology exists for
humanity but certainly not anytime soon
um
rovers represent in every conceivable
way a better option
and he's like you know
yet there is something inspiring in a
way that we somehow need as humans
when you picture that image of boots on
the ground
on the martian surface you know looking
at that same our same sun but from a
completely different location in the
solar system
that there's something about that that
stirs something up in us
that that is different and it's funny i
remember a different
scientist they were always saw on a
panel once in our debate about this
subject
and another person said the only reason
people want
to watch a human expedition to mars is
because of the
reality tv sort of are they going to die
like that they said that's the thing
that would keep people invested just the
the drama of the armstrong was
a few decades before the invention of
reality tv wasn't and i think a few
people watched that
yeah well
like reality tv is an iteration on
coliseum well i think both speak to the
same subject
it's all related in the sense that we do
experience the world through humanity
right the the idea of like
we the reason we follow a football team
we like or the reason that we care about
a stranger landing on the moon they are
all
or a celebrity in a reality tv show is
because
ultimately we're social creatures and
humanity
we think of ourselves as an individual
but we're also the only species that
thinks of ourselves as a society as a
group of people
as a community and therefore our
communities achievements and people we
associate with
we feel good when a creator we like does
make something awesome and get
successful right like we
we feel good when a musician we love
gets number one you know
there's there's a there's a relationship
we have to the people who even if we
don't know them personally
there is that community and i think it's
similar here is like i don't have any
relationship emotionally to a rover
i'm intrigued by the scientific outcomes
of that journey but it doesn't mean
anything
whereas a human on the on mars that's
that's someone from my tribe achieving
something and i'm proud of it
you know that's my greater tribe watch
there's a documentary called five years
on mars and
they are um it's documentary or
documenting
uh curiosity and um
what was the other one opportunity uh
opportunity
um and how those two
and it's of course you can contextualize
and anthropomorphize
and you're like curiosity runs into
trouble when they find out that you know
whatever but dude when curiosity died
died dude i cried
i was like what did they do in that
movie did they did they cut to people in
the control room feeling bad did they
play music
that's happening
you know panels they're just like you
know they drop their heads and you're
connecting with the human that's
that's my point i guess is a broader
point is that there's a there's a reason
we anthropomorphize that's like a way of
us
understanding things that aren't human
because ultimately we're designed
to interact with other humans that's our
whole didn't
um didn't japan land a rover on the moon
and like write a bunch of tweets on its
behalf that were like i i
sit here embracing the darkness that
will soon befall me and it was like this
i think i think curiosity did the same
thing i think curiosity
yeah the curiosity one the curiosity one
was very like today i'm gonna take a
soil sample it was very
upbeat but this one was like a werner
herzog
like monologue as there is no lives
yeah because isolation is all there is
on mars
the darkness surrounds us and yet we
reach forward
why how i don't have hands
but i still extend them for
the necessity of i don't know um it's
good
ralph has a great quote that says all of
humanity
or all of history exists for the sake of
a single human
and it's because we look at the pyramids
and we go to build on your point mike we
look at the pyramids
and go somebody did that or we look at a
painting and go somebody did that
they were human if you know we can talk
about the pyramids being aliens whatever
but
you look at anything that's great the
same thing with like a football team
um it's great and
if they did that then i can i'm capable
of doing greatness
but i also think that's why people are
so critical is because
they look at it and there is that
relationship to them
there is a little bit more familiarity
it's the same reason why
uh louis uh louis c.k talked about this
is like the
the behavior that we exhibit when we're
driving on the highway somebody cuts us
off
we would never act that way if
we were at the elevator with somebody
and they get
in their face you piece of [ __ ]
help you die i hope you die yeah there's
a social contract right we're all very
conscious of
our place and our our interactions with
people around us for sure
did you just go wait who did such
contrast john
no uh descartes no brian deckhardt
i got to see him this weekend wait a
minute who did social contract uh
[ __ ] what are you asking
who did social who wrote social contract
that's uh
aaron sorkin
oh it was 600 pages long
[Music]
i genuinely don't know what you're
asking but it sounds very exciting
is there a book called social contract i
assume
yeah that was written by um
oh my god
you mean like the political philosophy
no no no no sorry
jean-jacques rousseau is the one that
came up with uh
social contract interesting that was his
that was his book
you know it's funny i never actually
knew that that was a book i i've always
been familiar with that as a
point of political philosophy but i've
never known that it was sprang from like
a published work
uh i don't know how i didn't know i know
that because i probably knew that in
high school and have long since
forgotten it but i
yeah it's like as a kid when you see a
shakespeare play and you're like oh he's
using that phrase it's like no he
invented that phrase yeah
yeah principles of political right what
what a
interesting book this would be to read
now um yeah i know this because of
uh ken levine and and ken was was always
um a very big proponent of uh
the social contract um
how did you get here dude we've covered
a lot i said something pretentious
basically i uh jesus we talked about
it's funny because i had a i had e3
though how about that e3
i know i tried by the way i'm point of
order
i watched for homework i watched a lot
more of e3 than i normally would because
of this
show and we have not talked about any of
it i've also been playing the living
hell out of
of uh resident evil village uh figuring
it would come up here
really yeah i'm almost to the end um
and um but
look at the time
mike you do it what was your e3
takeaway mike give us that at least give
us a taste my e3 takeaway
my biggest one was just stop talking to
the camera
all of you that was yeah i saw a tweet
from you about something about that what
was it i just i feel like yeah i think i
think the nintendo direct model works
really well which in fairness does have
some talking but it's very quick very
bite-sized
here's a chunk of information there's
another chunk of information and i think
the ones that were least successful i
saw
were were the ones where it was like a
lot of chatter there was there was
somewhere they were like literally like
doing an interview for like 10 minutes
with someone or whatever and it was
tyson
i tweeted that and immediately someone
said oh troy won't like that and i feel
like maybe i didn't see one where troy
talked
did you talk at something at e3 did you
do something
oh okay fair enough then i don't know
what that guy was talking about then but
yeah i was that was my biggest thing is
i think
we might be past the awkward exec in a
t-shirt and
suit jacket coming out and you know big
expansive hand gestures introducing
something
i say there's someone who has done the
jacket with the t-shirt underneath and
that talk on stage
but like i think that nintendo might
have killed that idea
because the ones you need nintendo and
microsoft that didn't do that i'm gonna
you feel like we still need a
four-walled event for e3 or do you feel
like
this undeniably brill builds hype right
like i watched a lot of
pr for companies that i would not be
paying a massive amount
of attention to because it was an event
like there's still a value in the
cumulative i think wait paul
talks about it i gotta do i gotta do a
bit
thank you for watching play watch listen
that's troy baker
that's mike bithell hello
you're austin wintry underestimated the
lag
and that's a lot of peers thanks for
watching hey hey
unfortunately i know that's kind of what
i was hoping for but then you were like
getting into substantive content so i
was like all right i'm gonna do my
stupid bit and then carry on what what
that was and i guarantee it because
alana's brilliant she will 100
title the episode mike and troy's
controversial opinions about e3 because
of the last minute of conversation there
you guys talk about e3 it's like
starting
you've literally witnessed half of that
conversation that's what i was hoping
you'd talk about
we have not given you much of that
content yet we got a lot of changing
backgrounds on this show lately
i like those uh bed sheets made out of a
skinned
sand worm from beetlejuice that's very
specific
you like that this is true i'll let my
dad know
you really liked his vegetables he's
like i mean it's it's plausible that
those things roam wildly in australia
and you know he went home yeah australia
i can see it like every
yeah everything's outscale yeah mm-hmm
oh i love it we got
alana's here for six seconds and we
already got the krazynski
move so how did you guys like e3 um how
was that
was that good what do you think what's
an e3
what's e3 is that i missed e1 and e2 so
i didn't really want to jump in i'll
wait for any origins
what a great joke did you watch e3's
like no i feel like
i missed one and two so i didn't i don't
want to kill
and expo but you would still no it's an
electronics entertainment expo
electronics expert so that means yeah
you got entertainment but you didn't get
electronics or expo
which is technically ridley scott
reference from earlier there you go
but i don't think we did get any new
hardware and we did not have an expo
e1 that's a good point who who won e3
for you alana i'm interested in your
take you're not taking
i think xbox i feel like that was
probably the best conference for me
um and i feel like this year sort of
proved to me more than anything that e3
is
not necessary going forward that's
basically where we're at
anytime it's just troy's question yeah
what i like
is that her answer is is a
great response to the last question that
we asked but it is
no way correlated to the rest of this
conversation at all
yeah good luck enjoying the the
discovery process of where the last hour
has gone
and i have to figure out what to title
it's the last one that i wasn't on i had
a tough time
yeah just figure that out it was
difficult i almost feel like the new
format should be just one of us
just joins in like the last five
basically chat roulette the podcast
[Laughter]
i don't know what you guys were talking
about it's basically a measure
it's basically a measure of like
navigational drift like we all start in
the conversation at the beginning then
one person leaves
for ten minutes and comes back to see
how far away
we've gotten since the or how crushingly
in the same place we still are yeah true
that's the that's the two speeds of this
show uh zero and one
yeah there's no there's no it's a binary
show
it's true so uh troy how's moving going
you're looking at it yeah i like country
troy i really do yeah
he's got to wear a singlet he's it's a
full movement mode
a singlet yeah that's called
pants because i couldn't find any so
this is it
troy couldn't find his feet apparently
he got away yeah you're moving underoos
everybody has them it's all right but
did you move house or did you just move
the studio room
oh no whole house i don't know the
details of this wow
yeah transplants to a different
household
i'm literally looking out at a barn
right now
yeah he's way outside the city way
outside
um which is super fun and like
the the the whole i'm just kidding i am
wearing pants
um
no i i i the the you know
revolving door of of of people who are
coming to do perform various tasks that
i'm not
you know neither allowed to nor um
uh trained to do and like yesterday was
i felt really weird and bad about it
because the the cable guy came
and he just did not want to be here
always like yeah we got
you got to find this thing i'm like i
don't i don't know
what what you you're using a glossary of
terms that are
very endemic to your job and you
understand what they are
i have no idea what any of those things
are and that's why you're here
if i knew what you were talking about it
was like yeah you got to find
the box i was like i don't know what
that would look like and i don't know
where that would be located you're like
yeah
like dude something is like yeah i can't
do it i'm like why is like well
your lines messed up i'm like what does
that mean so long story short is like i
don't get
internet for like and great
you know we did last night we talked
i had to talk to my wife are you okay
did it go down all right
it was the airing of grievances uh
traveler is like ryan's like what
what have you been up to travelers with
all of it
he's he's just like he's loving it he's
got room to run around
we haven't brought 8-bit yet we're gonna
pick him up now
today and bring him back and he just i
gotta i gotta figure out a way because
there's no fence really so i gotta keep
everybody in
and that's like that was the same walk i
was like ah this is beautiful where's
everybody
it's like wrangling wrangle my blonde
boys
i'll get i'm glad everybody will be able
to see how this thing grows and
will get dirty with each other i think
your background has changed more than
anyone else's and i'm in australia
yours has gone through like so many
transformations over time
and you do green screen too so like you
you can change your background every
time and mine still looks the most
changed yeah you get an award for that
that's my game of show e3 is
choice ever changing background you win
uh best evolving game
of uh 2021. nice slash 20 excellent ray
tracing behind you on that wall
yeah yeah excellent it was very
publishing deal is [ __ ] though
so
so i did play the one stadia exclusive
that came out i think it was called
guilt
gylt i remember poor choices i think it
was cool
yes and it was actually pretty good
i was all right with it that that
company had no marketing department
because there's no way you call your
name guilt
i'm i could be wrong about the no that's
i think that's i think that's what it
was a buddy of mine i think it scored
that game which is the only way i even
knew
it existed also like it was like wait
we're gonna yeah what's called
lost so was that like an indie project
i've not heard anything about this game
is that like a game
yeah it's not a huge i don't think it
could have been indian because i think
it was published by stadia but sorry go
ahead
i'm talking [ __ ] and there's people that
worked hard on that game and i'm not
trying to you know throw anybody on the
bus it caught me as funny that the name
of
the game would be guilt yeah yeah like
i come up with the shittiest name so i'm
i'm owning it right now before someone
either either i
i seriously i don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings i
i can't name things for [ __ ]
so the fact that you chose a name is is
a better version of mine and what we're
talking about which is better vision
iteration so hopefully you iterated on
that name and you felt good about it and
people
made enough money to continue to make
games i think
yeah if they were a platform exclusive
they'll have they'll hopefully have done
okay out of it it's
um the tagline for the game is shape
your fears
fear the shapes which i don't even feel
like is necessarily
very accurate for that game it was like
a a real spooky
um almost like little nightmares in vibe
except that it was third person uh where
you're like a kid in a school and as
the spooky stuff in school and it was
like i enjoyed what i played of it
and it ran smoothly i always had a weird
experience with stadia where for me
in la my connection was actually
wonderful and i could play video games
while the rest of the world was yelling
at me about how it was the worst thing
in the world i was like well i
understand that this is technically
subjective because it's streaming
but stadia does work for me i should try
it while i'm home actually see the
comparison
probably wouldn't be so great the very
famous australian sort of
wonky ass internet world-leading oh you
want
yes is that your provider there well
yeah yeah we've got one
guess the internet even i did my own
accent wrong to play along with that bit
i said yes as well oh you know
do you need any uh any internet today
you're gonna get wonky ass internet
because i'm happy to come out see it
and give you a wonky ass all day it's
just ass not yes
oh yeah i'm sorry i'm not really ticking
but otherwise it's great
[Laughter]
yeah troy's not really looking for
directions
[Laughter]
thank you for that though but i
apologize you're right it was i stepped
over a line you're a professional
unsolicited i won't i won't do it again
i'm really sorry about that my
i love that troy looks more like he's in
australia
he really does look like he's recording
from australia he really looks like he's
awesome
how do i leave the meeting i'm trying to
leave him well i can do that for you
are you asking for my series
do that at some point well i tried to do
a very bit bitty
but you should do it for real
i don't think that it makes any
difference but uh okay hello everyone
thanks for watching play watch listen i
don't know what this episode was about
but i know that it wasn't about e3 which
is what i hoped it would be about i'm a
lot of peace i'm a video game writer
that's mike pickles he's a video game
director that's awesome
no that's awesome winter he's a video
game question that's troy becky he's a
video game actor
are you auctioning us that was uh yes
i don't know how they do it it's very
impressive do they have knowledge
amazing
do they have notes how do you just do
they rehearse
i mean troy troy's troy's a great voice
actor he's not that fast is he you know
what i mean like he's not got the
he's alright can you auction us please
can you auction this can you do that
request
because of course
is he selling four speakers oh he's
selling
all of us i see i thought you were
talking about speakers
that was good that was good i'm sorry
i think that there's a psychology behind
that that they are
told that they should speak that quickly
because it gets people excited or
panicked or rushed oh a hundred percent
like
you're getting it and the point of an
auctioneer
is motivation and to move people to
compulsive
buying absolutely wow you're you're
missing it you're missing that it's
about to go
coming right now five five nine six six
i'm gonna go to six nine who's gonna
make a seven you're gonna
got seven right now got a seven seven's
gonna make it eight who's gotta eat
right now they got eight hundred
eight hundred and nine and it's just
constantly moving to where you
feel the pace of it and you're about to
lose out it's it's total fomo
i can tell you i once i once uh
hosted a charity gala and i had to be an
auctioneer
and that was i didn't even try to do the
super fast talking but i
i found that just
keeping tabs with the crowd and
remembering where the [ __ ] number
currently was
was incredibly difficult
like wow okay you know we're auctioning
off uh i can't even remember what the
items were it was it was a fundraiser
for a youth orchestra
um and we were doing it at um
ucla this was this huge group of seats
so like hands would go up and i'd say
okay
you know all right i got 900 over there
uh and then i'd look down and i'd see
like a friend of mine and tell me like
you know
johnny you're not going to let them get
away with this sorry 900 and then very
suddenly i realized like just
by engaging with this person i'm like
did i say 900 because
two seconds earlier it was 800. and
three seconds before that it was
seven so i'm going and i'm picturing
okay the next thing i'm gonna say is a
thousand and then my mind would go
did someone already do that have i
already said a thousand and very quickly
i'm like this job is this is actually
not an easy job
or i'm just hilariously bad at it uh i
mean it's also
barely possible i'm just gonna do it
silent auctions
also do better than people calling out
because it's an easier it's just
this as opposed to people will be more
inhibited
if they have to announce their price
i i've seen game theory isn't it it's
also game theory that people are trying
people are people are imagining the
highest number they could imagine
someone else paying
which is actually the number they would
pay otherwise so you're
so you're over betting on what your
perceived value of the item if you think
something's worth ten dollars
in a silent auction you're gonna go ah
other people are gonna go ten dollars
i'll double it twenty dollars and if
everyone has the same mentality it just
keeps pushing it out
i haven't i was just saying basically
i've seen that both ways though because
i've
i've um
like we do my my music education
nonprofit
pre-covet at least we always would do an
annual gala and we'd always do
a live auction and a silent auction and
i would
always see those dynamics where you know
two people get into a bidding war in the
silent auction where they keep you know
writing in the number walking away
looking over their shoulder they see the
other person walk up and it's like
passive aggressive college roommates who
keep going and changing the thermostat
without talking to each other
and so they circle back and it's like
god damn it so you see that these two
names going back and forth back and
forth back and forth
and i've been in that position two once
i remember i i was i was
going up against a cellist at a
musician's fundraiser once
for uh a i know what i'm inviting by
saying this out loud but i
it was for a custom outgoing voicemail
greeting recorded
for you by randy newman uh
[Laughter]
i'm going to send it to you he did it
for my parents and the best part was you
actually won
i want it i want it i i bartered with
the musician i said tell you what
uh i'll i'll basically start hiring you
if i can just have this for my parents
uh
and because it was a cellist in the l.a
community who i didn't know and i was
like look you know i'm a composer
like can we make a trade here all i have
to offer is is
when i'm in a position to hire a cellist
i'll hire you
and uh which is a pretty good awful good
cellist though
yeah yeah definitely first call cellist
and but the although they were very
annoying in the moment because they were
like a veteran
who has played with randy newman a
million times and they go yeah i guess i
could just call him and ask him to do it
for me anyway
and i was like well then you should have
not let me add another thousand dollars
to the [ __ ] price before you came to
that conclusion
but uh it was four it was for a good
cause
yeah well in any case i've seen it both
ways
at our etmla ones um michael jacquino
often
does auctioneering um and uh
he's he's very good at the auctioneering
and he's done a good job and one time
the premier
item uh at our thing was he goes
like the number one night because it's a
room full of composers and
you know fancy hollywood people and he
goes
he goes uh the number one item tonight
is because this is raising money for our
like kids music charity so you know and
everyone's all
thoroughly liquored up by this point in
the evening so he goes okay
last item of the night the chance to go
bowling with me
and my agent who does not represent him
immediately raises his hand
and so then michael turns to his agent
and is like you know richard craft is is
bidding on this
you gotta let him get it so they bit
each other up to like
tens of thousands of dollars uh i mean
it was it was in like variety the next
day
of like and that's but that's not a
ridiculous business expense to have a
social action well no that was the
[ __ ] thing
the kind of royalties he does well
that's oh yeah yeah you're talking
you're talking
just the 10 agent thing would be worth
hundreds of thousands a year so they're
they're like they're they were like uh
you know richard said something like you
know
you know i'm to be clear i'm definitely
bidding for his
his contract as a as a as a client uh
and uh and uh so yeah they they they
agreed to
both spend the money and go bowling
together it's for charity it raised a
ton of money and then
and then no one went bowling
it was all it was all for show but
definitely that was one of those where
the number because of the theater of it
because there were hundreds of people
all watching
this go down they drove the number into
the stratosphere just for the
and of course these are all very wealthy
people who had money to burn
all three of those fellas got like a
halo effect benefit from it as well
right so it's kind of a win
win win yeah all the rest of us who were
pure spectators were just
laughing hysterically as it sure as it
got out of hand
and and uh and then it raised
non-trivial money for the program so
yeah it was
and i don't think that could have
happened without the theater
component to it so that's the best case
scenario for the live auction
over the silent auction psychology as
far as i can tell
i'm glad that we finally covered live
auctions
on the show this is
we're not afraid to tackle
the hard conversations that people
need to have yeah and i think that's the
thing with a lot of games media
it's you know it's too celebratory it
doesn't really dig into the big issues
but
yeah they're all trying to get jobs or
whatever do you get that mike
someone the other day because i wasn't
mean enough about sonic was like you're
trying to get a job at sega i was like i
don't know that i am
oh who did that happen it happened with
me the other day such a weird criticism
you're trying to get a job no
pretty happy with my job don't intend to
work it was mortal kombat it was more
combat
the more that was good and it was weird
i know a bunch of the writing team over
at wall combat it became a thing of like
mike you can't have a job you've got to
stop streaming
i just want a mortal kombat machine
that's awesome
oh they do look good though they do look
good though
damn it i don't think we don't even talk
about that movie
we didn't talk about the movie because
when we tried to talk about i was the
only one who had
seen it well i subsequently saw it
sub subsequently
all right go find it i'm excited for you
troy and i i look forward to
getting background updates i see your
elgato key light back there that's good
[ __ ]
um good luck setting all that up uh i
have one
no idea where the rest of them are and i
looked
that's a concern have you considered
having the
um 5 30 a.m sunlight as a podcast flight
because it it's pretty good we have like
i'm currently sun setting your sun
rising
and these guys are midday midday this is
an international
show it's a global show where we talk
about auctions
i like that you couldn't even i like you
couldn't even hold that voice through to
the end of the sentence it was it was
too ridiculous
we talk about auctioneering thank you
i i overheard at a home depot
someone said based on your clothing i
believe this is sorry this is this
better be
the free hot take that's all i want i
was at home depot someone was saying
that they
they really feel like there was a big
fable shaped gap in microsoft
presentation carry on
they could have they should have you
know look we've been building up to this
give us the games that we really want um
what i was gonna say doesn't really
matter it was just a visit no it does
it was it was a discouragement against
ignorant people
was all it was that's fair yeah that's
fast
try not to be ignorant but also being
ignorant is okay as long as you are open
to not being ignorant anymore because
sometimes you can be ignorant by
accident
oh you are you are you are literally
only ignorant by accident
uh i i think it's not i think you can
intentionally there are some people who
choose as a lifestyle
but they're not ignorant
as as uh the unknown unknowns like it's
one thing to say
i don't understand x or y and also
i choose not to like learn more about it
that to me is not
really what ignorance is though
ignorance is i don't know
i don't know what i don't know and i
don't there's is there a difference
between
ignorance and uninformed
look i think there's a difference in
perception of those two words but i
would say they technically probably are
the same thing being ignorant means you
just don't know about something
but i do think you can intentionally be
ignorant like you can intentionally not
watch the news because it's too
difficult that's right but you're saying
that
what i think i'm using the word ignorant
for is what you're saying
bigoted would be reserved for right oh
yeah
[Music]
i've never understood ignorant as a
pejorative
it's like let's writing music for games
is the most important thing in the world
to me and if i meet someone that has
no they are deeply ignorant to it
i'm not there in no universe is that
troublesome or offensive to me oh no i
don't think i don't think people use
ignorant
as a pejorative in that sense it's more
when people are ignorant about something
that you would expect a
functioning member of society to know
about so you know
ignorant like i am willfully ignorant
yeah but i think that's a that's a
poetic term more than it is
like logistically possible you know what
i'm ignorant about
the future of nintendo hardware because
they didn't mention uh
anything no no no no no no no yeah
alana i point of order second time i
want it noted i
tried to bring this back to e3 twice and
then
and then we talked to you succeeded that
means a lot to me thank you
did you mute him do that austin
i think ignorant applies as a negative
when i feel like it's like right now is
every day trans people get attacked just
transphobes just won't even have a day
off
and they often say [ __ ] that is just
ignorant as an excuse to justify
transphobia they are immediately
disprovable if they did their research
right
you're like this just isn't even true
because they just want to be
transphobic and i think that's where it
obviously applies as a negative is like
you haven't even looked into this
remotely you just listen to some dude
who doesn't know what he's talking about
on a podcast and then
started tweeting hate speech well in my
opinion
in my opinion the problem there is the
hubris of someone making declarations
without knowing the facts the
the the that's the inherent problem of
that scenario it's not that they don't
know
because not knowing a thing should just
never be a crime as far as i'm concerned
making big proclamations ignorant
applies
negatively i do i do agree that ignorant
is not inherently a bad thing
yeah i was open to being involved yes
but that then
if you are not open your lack of
openness is the problem not the
ignorance
correct i agree i agree that that's the
only point i'm making because people say
ignorant like
you're so ignorant and i'm like true but
call
you you can still say it like if i if i
said to someone
like you're basically arguing over the
difference between
so and so is smelly and so and so never
washes
both are things that you would criticize
them for one is a sin and one is the
outcome of
other sin right like it's like it's i
don't think you're you're i don't think
the smelly person is smelly and that's
not necessarily what you're saying
ignorance is the outcome of a sin
i'm saying in the case of i'm saying
yeah i'm
well i'm saying choosing to be ignorant
yeah ignorant
choosing to remain ignorant about
something that like you
are actively engaging with or attacking
people for is a sin in my opinion
well although the word sin i'm worried
about yes i feel weird about it no i
don't
know it's into this conversation that's
a bad thing if you're choosing to be
ignorant you're choosing to be ignorant
that's
and as especially as alana says when so
many of the things you hear bigoted
people say
are provably wrong with like literally
two minutes of googling like
literally just go and do your research
and find out i take that take note i
think it's possible i think you can
criticize them for that yeah i take no
issue with that
i just to me it's an important
distinction
because as someone who thinks that a
thirst for knowledge
is the highest call to adventure that we
could have
it is the most laudable
character trait in someone anything that
chastises
insufficient knowledge i bristle out
immediately
because sure that that suggests
you don't encourage someone to go learn
more when you criticize them for not
knowing enough today that's it doesn't
that's not good positive reinforcement
now i but that's why i say it's
important to
disentangle the idea that someone who
then goes out
and is an [ __ ] uh standing on a
foundation
of ignorance as their as their basis for
which
it's not that they don't deserve
criticism it's just that the [ __ ]
behavior is the thing that i take issue
with
not the fact that they don't know
something yeah i need an example
because i i think this is great that
that we've actually launched into this
without even discussing what what
the primer for it was i heard somebody
say
oh yeah i never actually had your pump
depot story
yeah you oh my god
oh you kind of yeah what do you mean i
thought you did that on purpose
you come to this country you better
speak the language
and that's what you've changed since you
moved to the country uh troy it's
uh that was a quote
i heard this at home depot coming out of
my mouth in fairness but
[Laughter]
yeah in this country you better learn
to speak the language this is america we
speak english
well that's actually not accurate is it
i was like that's what i'm saying
it was like first of all i i wanted to
stop so bad and go
excuse me uh it's [ __ ] right
um yeah i mean i fundamentally disagree
with that
but i wanted to ask them generally do
you know
that there is that america has no
national language and number two my
follow-up is
the language isn't i speak american
the language is i speak english which
was brought to us
by another country
and they just left it and this is what
we speak
we didn't create our own language
we like ad hoc and appropriated it in
certain ways
and since then there have been other
languages you know that have
you know an enormous amount of the
population of america speaks that on
english right and those have grown as
well
it was really interesting on a very on a
related note was um
watching in the heights uh which which
has um
which has non-subtitled spanish language
in it
and it's just one of those things where
you're like oh that's that's interesting
that's
that's not that's that's that's kind of
surprising but at the same time
completely not surprising because that
is a language
that to the american audience is is part
of the culture is part of
part of the part of the space and it was
just it was interesting seeing that
transition take place
also amazing film by the way like i said
i'm a big musical theater
i loved it i i think we talked about
this before i'm really weird about
musicals that are shot as film it's
i'm gonna sell it to you very quickly
then because it is like
it's it's a good musical like in the
heights it's the it's the show that my
miranda did before hamilton it's it's a
good
solid musical but the film adaptation
adds so much to it
in terms of what's the um it's the
director of um
crazy rich asians right um and it's so
visually creative and it adds so much to
it that it's
yeah it's genuinely like i guess
my the best musical i've seen since
possibly since rocket man
and before that there weren't many like
rocket man was the last like excellent
film musical i think i saw
um well i haven't been yeah you should
watch it if you not watched it
it struggled because it was um released
near the very very bad
um queen one i can't what was that
called bohemian
but rocket man which i think a lot of
people skipped because of how bad
bohemian rhapsody was but like no rocky
man's an excellent
it's a musical like it's it's they're
singing in scenes it's not
i have very mixed feelings about in the
heights but i do agree i liked
i liked the the straight-faced way that
it handled
the the the language interplay for sure
um
and i do think that like a transition in
american filmmaking it felt like like
this is a mainstream film for a big
hollywood studio that's
not subtitling the spanish that's cool
i'll say just
one thought on the whole
american official language concept is
i one of the things that i do love
about this country is the inherent
pluralism of it and
you know like when you when you go to a
like a very service-y kind of business
like if you look up on google for
example
uh it's very typical that it'll say like
these are the languages that this
company supports
um and it'll be you know like our
employees expand like a restaurant our
employees speak
you know spanish uh uh korean
you know russian whatever they'll list
like here's what we've got
on offer and i've always loved that i
always think that that's
and and i've always loved it's admirable
yeah and i've and i remember
when i was in new york um
spending time with my cousins my
grandfather's cousins you know they're
like whatever that makes them my third
cousins or whatever
the term would be but they were in their
80s
um 70s and 80s at the time um
the brother it was a brother sister the
the the brother siegbert
ziggy he you know he came to the us
from germany when he was a teenager and
didn't speak any english but but he
spoke basically every european language
including turkish crazy enough and and
uh
and so when we would get into attack and
he speaks all fluently
you know french french german um
uh portuguese spanish italian
um hebrew turkish this guy's
unbelievable and we'd get into a cab and
he'd look at the
the license of the driver and off their
name
he'd know where they're from he'd
know a few words you know he could speak
those languages fluently but he picked
up random phrases
so he'd say hello to them and i mean
like nigerian i mean it was unbelievable
and they would always turn and be they
would
shocked that but the thing that was
always to me so endearing about these
scenarios
is because he was an immigrant as well
he didn't speak a word of english so
as an immigrant who came to the u.s
eager to
find his footing and you know of course
in his case he was also fleeing nazi
germany
but but the part of the immigrant story
one of the ironies of the whole
uh you better learn to speak the
language uh
my two takeaways there is first the
the irony is that almost always the
immigrants end up speaking english
far more eloquently than the natives the
locals like the american
natives you know what i mean i don't
obviously mean to dip my toes into that
water but you know what i mean
like born and bred americans often don't
speak
english as well as those that learned it
as a point of
of pride and as part of their immigrant
story i mean
the most some of the most beautiful um
english i've ever heard has been through
the accent
of somebody who didn't grow up with it
the second point that i
would raise is that i saw a meme making
its way
around um instagram the other day
that i think relates to this subject
which is also anytime you've ever heard
somebody speaking english
with a thick non-american accent
you know hispanic accent of of
innumerable
potential flavors you know eastern
europe or
from asia or india or wherever there is
an inherent
courage just by virtue of that person's
speaking
because here's somebody who likely did
not speak the language
came to a country full of people that
only speak that language
and did the work to learn it and so and
and i was like
well speaking uh on behalf of a
uh my costa rican girlfriend who had no
confidence in her english when she first
came to the us a few years ago you know
it was like
yeah you know you the idea that you
would feel self-conscious over your
english which
is is baffling to me because you speak
multiple [ __ ] languages that's better
than
about 300 million of us here including
me yeah how many people who are who are
in someone making an indictment about
someone who can't speak english
perfectly
speak any other language yeah any other
phrases many of them struggle with the
one language they do speak absolutely
yeah i've always found that at our at
our old house
my neighbor across the street wonderful
affable
um congenial uh neighbor
from from paris and i've been taking
french for the last year
i still felt inhibited
and almost embarrassed to strike up a
conversation with him in french
and the moment that i started was like
what are you doing i'm like i've been
learning french for last year's like why
haven't you been i'll help you what do
you want to
you know i would love to be able to have
this beautiful thing where we come
outside
and it's like how was your day today and
we can have this like small you know
perfunctory conversation in french
when my dad was growing up when my um
we did it we're doing it
[Laughter]
when my dad was growing up he you know
his father
was part of that wave of my family who
was fleeing the nazis in 38 and came to
the u.s so my father was
he and his siblings were the first ones
born here
and my grandfather you know found a
community
of fellow uh immigrant slash
refugees um who all were european you
know
um uh uh you know
like multilingual types like we're
talking about
and my dad said as a kid he would see
them all
sitting around a table and one would
have like a yiddish joke so they'd
start speaking hebrew to tell the joke
because it's funnier in that it's not
it's not only funny it's only funny in
that language like it's built around
some
pun or whatever in the so they all start
laughing and then they just keep
speaking in that language without really
noticing and then someone would have
like an italian joke
and they'd all just shift to italian
without noticing and he was like they
would just move around europe with their
languages
as they like us someone would tell a
joke or make a little crack that's
funnier in
in in german so they'd all just switch
to german and my dad was just watching
this as a kid like
holy [ __ ] that's the coolest thing i
ever saw i lived in an international
house when i first moved to the u.s for
six months which means it's
exclusively international people um
which is pretty cool
and one of the i was one of the only
people who was
english first language almost everyone
else was from a non-english speaking
country
and one of the it still sticks with me
one of the most profound things that i
ever heard it was a
portuguese girl asked a german girl do
you dream in english
and i was just like oh my god it's like
i've never thought about the idea
of dreaming in another language because
you know multiple languages
and she was like yeah just the other day
because i've been in america for like
three months or whatever now all my
dreams are in english and i don't even
know where it happened and just
listening to this conversation and being
like that is a world that
i have tried to get into i've tried to
learn french and german multiple times
but i always give up but these people
are so far gone that they're living in
another country that's a language they
don't speak and they're dreaming
in another
like a dimension of perception that
you'll you don't have access to and
that's what i'm so jealous of people
respect the hell out of it
yeah it's amazing like the idea of like
philosophy in different languages and
the idea of like just
the way and i've spoken to people i've
got a hungarian friend
who who said like he thinks differently
in hungarian than he does in english
when he's thinking in english because of
the structure of english is a language
his brain works differently i find that
fascinating
it is it is so great when you start like
for me learning french the way that it
is a
but it's the math of the words is like
if i say
you know uh look at yourself in the
mirror whatever it's like
to te you have to say i you yourself
look at you and the mirror kind of thing
it's like the the way that the reflexive
pronouns work
well even like what is it le chateau
would be the black cat but even that is
the cat black the other way around i
find that so hard to get around and also
like
spanish french is the same feminine and
masculine words were always the thing
that
that made me stop that i got too
confused with grammar is weird but the
thing that i love about that specific
example is like what we're talking about
is the cat
not the color and this thing is the most
it's a descriptor of this thing but this
thing is what i'm talking about and it
kind of keeps transparent
have you familiar with how slavic
languages have what's called the case
system
uh i had a roommate in college who was
studying russian and i was studying
latin and they both used the case system
and it made latin
it's it had there's no corollary to this
in english at all because
in the same way that we conjugate um
that we conjugate verbs uh
you know to to change tense and things
like that
um case you case nouns
which is a way of um it adds
information about your relationship to
the thing like you're
you're i'm trying to remember it's it's
hazy and i'm sure that comments will
happen i just googled it there are six
distinct
cases in latin nominative genitive
dative accusative ablative and vocative
and there are vestiges of the seventh
the locative that's
what that's basically basically the case
basically the way the way in which you
say the way in which you case a noun
gives the listener information about
your relationship to that noun like if
you believe
if you if you know the truth of what
you're saying for example
versus you're not sure or like i own
this object versus i don't
that kind of thing you're providing
you're providing information about your
relationship to that
which means that for me as an english
speaker where there's no equivalent to
this at all
trying to build a sentence it felt like
3d chess i was having to think
about so many things to even just start
the process
and it was like you know they do this in
russian by default wow and i just
thought
jesus christ why this is why
scripture gets so
[ __ ] convoluted is because
nobody understands the context in which
it was written
it was a guy writing to a
a group of people that lived over there
about the [ __ ] that was going on
for them at that time and then everybody
else ever was like
i guess this applies to everybody in the
world well not just that ever about
everything and it's going to be
translated through three or four
languages yeah what was it actually
written in originally
it depends there's there's the bible
greek latin
uh or aramaic um or hebrew
so depending upon because it's written
over a span of you know
but also also add to that that the
the contents of the new testament were
basically transcriptions
like a century later of oral traditions
like
so you're you're you're you're
you're also getting you know
like the idea of the gospels as first
job didn't sit down and write that
job told that story to someone who told
that story to someone who told that
story
apparently the christian new testament
is widely agreed to have originally been
written in greek
right the new testament was greek
because that's what they would have
spoken at the time
where they were at but yeah like john
the gospel of john
is like the first of them that was
written and it was the only one that was
like written by
him and it was written after it was like
written like
i thought paul was the only one that was
uh was
uh the because paul's kind of the
church father uh i thought paul all the
others are here we go
pseudonyms peter peter would be the
father of the church paul was the
the considered the apostate that came in
after the fact he was the one that
he was the nazi that became a jew yeah i
know yeah who was
who was the um who wrote the page from
red dwarf where it says all characters
it contained here in a fictional and
resemblance to real people living or
dead
they cut that book out of the bible that
that page
that was really great boy a lot of world
history would be different if that page
hadn't gone missing
i think it's the pilot episode of red
dwarf is like a news reporter saying
like
we've discovered a new page of the bible
it's that is that really oh that's so
funny
someone i knew went to seminary and um
they said
once you understand that the book of
genesis
was written as poetry
yeah and it was never it was the same
way that i think about that scene in
galaxy quest
where here they are in space and you
know these the
real aliens come to them and like we
watched your historical documents
they're like
and then there's a there's a tv show
like we based our entire society off of
this
right that's exactly it was never moses
never went i was like
seven dead no i'm not i'm i'm
i'm a raging i'm a raging atheist but
i've got to admit even i when i read
genesis
genuinely like in a weird way it's
actually to me the part of the bible
that
makes like that feels closest to like
[ __ ] this might have actually because it
is how you would explain
every you know the big bang through to
that period in time to a child right
like if you were explaining these
concepts to like
an as a a pre-industrial culture that
doesn't understand
i'm don't get me wrong i'm definitely
this but like that was the only thing
that was like actually it
and then there was something like even
the word that is used
to to uh to say void
like there was there was nothing or
whatever is actually
a word that is in the same way that you
would look at lumber
and and describing like you're going to
build a house it's not that there was
never anything it was like well they're
all the materials were there
and then we used those materials and
built a house
it's it's just context is everything and
that's why i feel it's so important
for everybody to just attempt i've been
doing this on duolingo we're not
sponsored
obviously by anything i don't have any
partnership with them at all but it's
just
it's the that's what i used to use for
german
it's i think i think duolingo is [ __ ] so
you got your balance there we go
[Laughter]
proudly monolingual being able to sit
down and like
i'm english we we tend to just we have
different approach to how we are yeah
that's true
monolingual i used a book
i learned from the professor headmaster
peace be french
oh colonialism but like a point troy
yeah um
i'm really glad that there's resident
evil 8 dlc coming
uh capcom presentation as we were saying
i've been playing resin metroid looks
basically it's good point of genesis i
i've made it to heisenberg
uh yeah yeah okay you're pretty far
three
i know i i feel that i am pretty far
through i've got mine
it's a good game maybe we'll talk about
it one day that or a tunnel
i'm a couple hours in return i think or
maybe 90 minutes
great it is good we'll talk about it
eventually but for now everybody i also
have another meeting in 10 minutes this
is a long one huh
all right it's your fault because
engineering and ignorance
this is shut up austin let her get his
ass
i just want to i just want to point out
i just want to point out the irony that
we were like having fun and being
ridiculous and silly and then alana
shows up and immediately it's like yeah
but what is
ignorance do we hold the ignorant
responsible so
alana supposedly the agent of chaos and
yet somehow
uh here you are you immediately like
just threw us straight into substantive
conversation god damn it that was my
fault actually i brought up a home
the ignorant person at home depot that's
that'll trigger us you know how to get
us it's home depot
oh and on that note we'll see you next
week everyone bye